um my name is venkat guruswamy i'm a
senior scientist here at the simons
institute and it's my pleasure to invite
you to one of the highlights of the
simon's institute activities which is
the meet the fellows program
of talks uh introductions for two days
which happens at the beginning of both
the fall and spring semester um as you
as you might know from meeting other
fellows we have an amazing
large and diverse collection of fellows
semester after semester that is in fact
one of the the big highlights of the
simon's institute and that perhaps is
really the
you know singularly unique place with
such a concentration of postdocs focused
on theoretical computer science related
topics worldwide and uh and of course
the fellows are crucial for a lot of the
activities which happen in the programs
and all the things we get to brag about
as
products of the program so we
kind of uh celebrate that in the
beginning and to also to get to know the
fellows with this event which is you
know sequence of light lightning talks
by all the new fellows and any uh
existing fellows who are interested to
share updates and uh so that's what
we're going to be doing uh today and
tomorrow so we have a busy schedule of
amazing talks and uh so we'll begin it
now so just one request as you see the
schedule is quite packed with 15 minute
slots and the anticipation is that you
would do a 10 minute talk
and then i will uh
you know kind of indicate to you and
that gives us five minutes for q a um
transitions and so on so please try to
adhere to that and that will really uh
help and if you want to chat more i'm
sure there's plenty of break time and
other things you'll all be here this
semester so there'll be chances to
discuss in greater depth with that let
me um introduce the first session we're
going to have four fellow talks from the
graph limits and process of networks
program and the first talk is by claire
donat on understanding the geometry of
craft neural networks
okay thank you very much so yeah my name
is karen and i'm currently at the
university of chicago in the statistics
department and so i'm going to talk
about some of the work we're doing with
several students on understanding the
geometry of graphical networks so
perhaps we start off with a little bit
of introduction um in the types of
problems that we're considering we're
you know you can actually pretty much
understand and understand them as a data
integration problem so what you observe
is a graph on n nodes and that is
typically encoded through a binary
adjacency matrix and on top of that you
also
have node features so let's say they're
dimensional and in these types of
problems what you're interested in is
actually predicting a signal of interest
so whether it's node prediction or edge
prediction so perhaps as a little bit of
an insightful example so um the the
graph i showed here is from a paper by
zip nick argyl lescovec in 2018 and that
tries to use graphical networks to model
side effects of um interactions between
drugs and so in that case the adjacency
matrix actually um
sort of you know allows you to model
interactions between
drugs or
proteins so you have protein binding
activities and drug contractions so
different types of nodes different types
of features and the different types of
edges and what you're trying to do in
particular is for instance predict drug
drug interactions so
what is uh
has been the recent trend in machine
learning is to actually use graphical
networks for this kind of problem so
graph neural networks are basically an
adaptation of the deep neural network
machinery to the graph setting and it
relies on two essential
ingredients the first one is a spatial
convolution which you can understand as
a generalization of what cnns do to the
graph setting and the idea here is to
say well okay so i want to integrate
adjacency and node features how am i
going to do that so for each node i'm
going to sort of you know integrate make
a new representation of that node that
has its own features plus that of the
neighborhood and i do that by doing just
a simple like you could compare it to
message passing um so just a simple
weighted sum of that node's features
with its neighbors and the the sum
uh the weights are determined by the
choice of the convolution operator the
special convolution operator which
typically in the uh um gcn setting is
just the augmented adjacency which you
symmetrize by divising by the degree
matrix then of course you you know you
do like linearity plus bias nonlinearity
like the neural network but that's um
yeah uh just you know quite simple and
then the second ingredient is actually
the reconstruction objective because you
know you change these models end-to-end
okay so uh the problems with no like
this is an intro this has had no good
success across our problems et cetera
but there's still some issues which make
dns perhaps interesting um to study um
the first like you know you could say
mainly there are three main issues with
this type of techniques first of all the
properties are never very well
characterized like how do they actually
extract patterns and are able to
extrapolate for instance in this
particular example uh is it the case
that some spatial convolutions are
better suited to the study of
homophobic networks or interaction
networks like this one
you also have evidence that dnns are
sensitive to perturbations like for
instance edge deletion or additions and
in a setting like this one for instance
where you don't expect all drugs to be
well studied or characterized you
actually do expect a lot of edges to be
missing at least for now so this is also
problematic and finally of course the
nn's outputs are not very interpretable
nor are they in that with any measure of
uncertainty so this makes it very hard
to deploy in any sort of you know
practical decision making setting
so perhaps as a way of trying to
understand a little bit more of what
gnns are doing um it's good to go and uh
look at what you know people in the
statistics and implied mathematics
literature are doing and in particular
you know we have a rich um literature on
network models and so parametric
non-parametric etc and perhaps the one
that sort of is the most similar to uh
what dns are doing are latent space
models as proposed by for instance um
and so in that case the idea is that
well um you have an underlying manifold
m and what happens is to create the data
that you're actually observing uh what
you need is some sort of sampling
mechanism over that manifold so let's
say it's pi and based on these assembled
points on the manifold you can actually
generate their featured data and um
edges right so uh and for instance the
function g here uh could you know rely
for instance on the dot product between
the two um latent representations or uh
their distance etc depending on the type
of data and so genens are actually you
know can be compared to
one of such relations-based models
because what they're trying to do to
some extent is estimate this z here and
the way they do that is a little bit
akin to what virtual intelligence right
so they they try to mix in a way the
adjacency and the feature matrix to get
a representation of uh this matrix z
so with this in mind basically what we
could try uh to uh consider is to say
well actually okay so to try on the sun
perhaps a little bit what gnns are doing
um the buyers that they carry uh their
robustness etc maybe it could be
interesting to try and see well actually
well if they're trying to recover this
manifold like how are they doing uh how
are they doing at the job uh are they
also able to disentangle uh the manifold
from the actual uh something density so
today i'm just gonna talk about some
preliminary work that we've done on the
topic and we actually focus on just the
convolution operator and the idea here
is to say okay well one of the the
crucial ingredients in this type of
setting is this convolution and so we
distinguish two families of operators
here the symmetric versus the normalized
one
and this metric basically is just saying
okay well we're going to take the
adjacency matrix like dns right we're
going to add self loops except i have a
weight beta here right that allows me to
sort of almost interpolate between a dc
and and just a the simple mlp setting so
if beta is very large you could think
that's the the the notes feature the the
source node is dominating and then we're
going to divide by the degree matrix but
at the power alpha where alpha varies
between zero and one so you have this
kind of symmetric operations and then
you have the normalized um one where
basically you take the uh random work
version of this and where this gets
interesting is that well the reasons why
we did this was that um we are
interested in the resemblance between
operators uh between the operators that
the gn and convolution use right so
assume you were you had a model with no
uh node features where so you just you
know replace x by the adjacency and you
do sort of you know discrete convolution
like this right you you stack them up so
you have s uh k times identity and
diffusion map so something that has been
introduced in the early 2000s by
confidence
and um so the the two authors here
propose spectral embeddings of this form
here so basically they take uh a bit
like us the degree of the power alpha
times their similarity matrix between
objects they divide by the degree and
they take a continuous sort of you know
uh
power of this to actually recover the
underlying manifold
where this gets interesting is that
coefficient of actually comes from the
applied mathematics community and they
have very interesting discussions about
the uh potential of this type of
spectral embeddings to actually recover
the underlying laplace belt charming
operator they show that this embedding
typically is non-biased if there's
something uniform something distribution
on the manifold of uniform and they
actually discuss the case of non-uniform
sampling cases so something that is so
they have a nice theoretically grounded
framework and a discussion on effects
that don't really exist in the gnn uh
community
so uh the first thing we did was say
okay well you know they have actually a
discussion on like the importance of
choosing this alpha and the relationship
it has in uh sampling density and etc so
let's try it out so let's try and vary
for instance the
alpha so this is just uh experiments on
a synthetic sorry on cora so a well
established benchmark in the gnn
communities and here i'm sorry so like
the legends is a bit i changed the names
but the red is basically um the
symmetric
uh one and the blue is the
like random walk version of it and you
can see that there's an interesting
change of phase that's sort of you know
alpha equals zero five where the
performance starts to drop and this
effect is actually uh observed with
different magnitudes and uh
i guess amplitudes uh across different
data sets right where um it seems that
you know there's a local optimal at zero
five sometimes and then it dips
actually here it starts uh yeah i guess
the optimum is a bit later for uh i
guess so the random work version so the
blue one um the effect is a bit
different so this just goes to show that
choosing alpha is actually important and
must
intervene somehow in the geometry of the
manifold that is being recovered so we
basically in uh what we are we did so we
have very simple uh ways of trying to
understand actually um like the
geometric organization of the the
embeddings sort of in the the trying to
characterize um exactly for instance
where it is compared to like so this is
you know the bias term so it's where
it's anchored and the s
sorry the h is in a way the um like you
know how much it's uh it varies around
this uh bias term and you can actually
show uh through simple derivation that
when alpha is less than zero five this
bond is an increasing function of the
degree which means that um high degree
nodes are going to be able to spread
much more and that effect is actually
reversed as alpha increases
and this is a synthetic
experiment where you see alpha equals
zero two here and alpha equals zero
seven here and the blue the green the
blue nodes here are the high degree
nodes and you can see this sort of
reversal of you know they're on the
outskirts in a way of the data this is
the the latent component and uh where is
that the center as alpha increases
this effect is not so much present um
it's at least hindered when you're
considering um or normalized
convolutions
and uh so yeah so this is interesting
because it goes to show that in a way
your assumption uh so the for the the
row normal line so the um the symmetric
convolutions uh it goes to show that
alpha is actually important controls how
much variability your uh high degree
nodes have and those potentially what
kind of influence they must have so for
instance uh here as a function of alpha
we have two settings one the blue one is
the node decreases with the degree
whereas the noise uh increases with the
degree when for the the
brown one and you can see that uh as
expected to some extent for settings
where um the low degree nodes are more
uh trustworthy
um the performance actually higher when
alpha is equal to zero so they have
potentially more influence
so yeah so basically we do the same this
effect is actually a little bit hindered
uh uh for uh symmetric sorry uh row
normalized uh operators
and uh yeah i mean we have several plots
essentially uh let me conclude here
because my ten minutes are over so this
just um this is currently just like
partial uh conclusion on uh what we've
begun to do on trying to understand how
the different components of the dnn sort
of machinery relates to properties and
recovering um you know the underlying
manifold here it just goes to show that
um the right choice of like there is
such a thing as the right choice of
convolution operators it actually has um
is very much linked with what prior you
have on the degree like is the degree uh
an essential feature of the data set or
is it due to for instance assembling
density and are there ways to mitigating
away the
effects of this
and uh thank you very much for your
attention and
if you have any question i'd be happy to
take them
[Applause]
so the way we'll do is we'll take
questions while the next speaker sets up
so to uh keep going um
any questions
we have time for a quick question
it's a thing that we could look at
currently right i guess we try to look
as well um like the curvature as well
like just empirically if it has to do
that's something we're uh trying to
understand as well like you know it's
you know like the degree is the simplest
in a way um setting but it seems to be
highly created so far so
thank you for the talk i'm wondering you
mentioned the use of diffusion maps and
my understanding is that in general use
it when the manifold is non-linear is
that something that you're looking at to
characterize like different linearities
in the manifold described by the data
i'm curious about details on that yeah
pretty much what we're trying to to do
is try to understand so there's um the
the way gnns operates is very
reminiscent of the diffusion maps and
there's like this nice theoretical uh
framework and they are a non-linear sort
of you know embedding uh method right
there allow and they actually show that
you can recover the flashback from the
operator and so the
dnns do that but on top of that they
have this added difficulty that they're
actually using no features on top of
that right so um but still you know if
you again take x to be just the identity
you sort of put back into the diffusion
map setting and so yeah basically what
we're trying to understand is how um you
know dnn sort of you know uh
in a way are an approximation of the
diffusion map or do they actually
convert to the same thing from different
angles or and is there anything we can
actually learn from the diffusion map
setting that also transfers to uh gnn
settings so for instance all their work
on on saying well you know what for
instance when the you can't assume that
the sampling distribution is uniform
like what does it mean for the you know
recovery of the patients of the
of the manifold uh it's an exam so
all right uh thanks for the great talk
and uh let's continue um
the next talk is beijuango and on
transmission movements